blog tu veux toi des toits des doigts
pendant qu'une machine au québec c'est
la grand messe du parti républicain la
convention
[Applaudissements]
ce moment tous les quatre ans où les
membres du parti les élus resserrent les
rangs avant une élection cette année on
n'y a surtout vu des citoyens ordinaires
et la famille de chanter ses louanges
pas d'anciens présidents pas de leaders
historiques très peu de parlementaires
des absences qui en disent long le
républicain jeff flake par exemple a
quitté le navire et votre à démocrates
pour la première fois de sa vie
selon cet ancien sénateur de l'arizona
le parti républicain a perdu son âme ses
valeurs et n'est plus aujourd'hui qu'un
culte de la personnalité fait partie
d'un groupe d'une vingtaine de ténors
républicains qui ont annoncé
publiquement faire défection
incapable de soutenir c'est le cas aussi
de tous et steve la nature je ne veux
pas être dans le parti de toronto mme
dit il et c'est ce qui est devenu le
parti républicain y croire cet ancien
stratège républicain
un conseiller de george bush john mccain
et métro ramené ils s'alarment en voyant
les figures actuelles du parti qui
détestait auparavant dans notre homme et
se respectent ces neuf avec ce maître
aujourd'hui à plat ventre devant le
leader je n'aurais jamais cru dit il
voir le parti accepte un programme qui
dit grosso modo peu importe que devant
tom veut nous soutenons sa capture c'est
un peu poursuit-il comme un serment
d'allégeance au führer
depuis quelques semaines les groupes
d'électeurs républicains déçus se
multiplient au mollet
ils expriment de plus en plus
ouvertement leur rejet de donald trump
dans une posture animé par l'igr stevens
lui est convaincu d'une chose on croit
qu'il va perdre l'élection et le parti
républicain devrait faire un sérieux
examen de conscience s'il ne veut pas
devenir complètement marginal ici jean
françois bélanger radio-canada
washington